la temperatura de un vaso de agua
caliente después de ponerlo en un
refrigerador se representa en la
siguiente tabla y aquí tenemos la tabla
donde el tiempo está en minutos y la
temperatura que está en grados celsius
es decir la temperatura dada para un
tiempo dado y después nos preguntan cuál
modelo para cdt es decir la temperatura
del vaso de agua de minutos después de
refrigerado es el que mejor se ajusta a
los datos y aquí tenemos estos cuatro
modelos así que una vez que ya los viste
sería buen momento para que pausa el
vídeo y veas cuál de estos cuatro
modelos es el que mejor se ajusta a los
datos
muy bien esperando que ya lo hayas hecho
ahora vamos a trabajarlo juntos y lo
primero que quiero que veas es lo
siguiente aquí en estos cuatro modelos
tenemos dos modelos lineales y dos
modelos exponenciales así que sería muy
bueno recordar a qué me refiero con un
modelo lineal y a qué me refiero con un
modelo exponencial para que un modelo
lineal sea el correcto necesitas tener
cambios fijos en el tiempo y también
tener cambios fijos en la temperatura es
decir cambios iguales en el tiempo me
van a dar cambios iguales en la
temperatura mientras que si pensamos en
un modelo exponencial lo que necesitamos
es cada vez que cambie el tiempo
multiplicar la temperatura por un factor
en común eso quiere decir que entonces
el cambio del minuto 1 al minuto 2 o de
minuto 2 al minuto 3 no va a tener un
cambio fijo lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar por un mismo factor vamos a
estar multiplicando por un mismo factor
así que vamos a ver qué opción se ajusta
mejor
para eso veamos qué es lo que pasa con
nuestros cambios en el tiempo y en la
temperatura en el tiempo si observas
vamos a hacer un cambio de dos minutos
así que déjame ponerlo así delta de tm
va a ser igual a dos minutos mientras
que la temperatura que es lo que va a
pasar bueno primero qué te parece si
pensamos en un modelo lineal si pensamos
en un modelo lineal cuanto hay de 80 a
60 y 4.3 se observa lo que hicimos fue
restar restamos 15.7 entonces nuestro
cambio va a ser de menos 15.7 bien esto
si lo pensamos como un cambio lineal
pero si lo pensamos como un cambio
exponencial lo que necesitaríamos es
multiplicar por un factor y como
encontraríamos ese factor bueno para eso
habrá que pensar por qué factor voy a
multiplicar a 80 para llegar a 60 y 4.3
entonces vamos a pensarlo de este lado
como un modelo exponencial y bueno para
encontrar ese factor que te parece si
dividimos 60
punto 3 entre 80 y para hacerlo más
rápido voy a traer por aquí a mi
calculadora y vamos a hacerlo 64.3 entre
esto me da 0.80 entonces redondeado esto
es aproximadamente x
0.8 muy bien entonces si lo pensamos
como un modelo lineal de 80 a 60 y 4.3
lo que hicimos fue restar 15.7 pero si
lo pensamos como un modelo exponencial
lo que hicimos fue multiplicar a 80 por
0.8 para llegar a 60 y 4.3 muy bien
vamos a ver qué pasa en los siguientes
dos minutos nuestro cambio otra vez es
de 2 minutos delta de tm es igual a 2
minutos y ahora vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa de 64.3 a 52.7 si lo pensamos
como un cambio lineal bueno lo que
tenemos que ver es cuánto le tuvimos que
quitar a 64.3 para llegar a 50 y 2.7 y
bueno si lo pensamos así 64.7 serían 12
unidades para llegar a 50 y 2.7 pero
estamos con 64.3 así que me quedarían
0.6 entonces le quitemos 11.6 muy bien
esto si lo pensamos como un modelo
lineal si lo pensamos como un modelo
exponencial entonces vamos a ver cuántos
52.7 entre 60 y 4.3 y de nuevo voy a
traer por acá mi calculadora y voy a
decir 52.7 esto lo voy a dividir entre
60 y 4.3 y esto me dá 0.81 casi 0.82 así
que déjame escribirlo esto me dan
aproximadamente 0.82 ahora podemos ver
otro cambio de dos minutos en el tiempo
que parece ser bastante bueno pero
solamente con ver esto que tenemos aquí
ya podemos darnos una idea de qué es lo
que está pasando si observas el cambio
en la temperatura en nuestro modelo
lineal no es tan cercano por una parte
tenemos menos 15.7
otra menos 11.6 lo que no es tan cercano
a comparación de aplicarnos en el modelo
exponencial donde si estamos
multiplicando por un factor que parece
común 0.8 entonces con esto estarías muy
tentado a decir que ese dt ya lo podemos
ver de la siguiente forma lo podemos ver
como el valor inicial que es 80 déjame
ponerlo con este color el valor inicial
que es 80 que multiplica al factor oa la
razón común que en este caso es 0.8
vamos a ponerlo así 0.8 esto elevado a
la t esto
elevado a la potencia tm pero ten
cuidado
esto sería cierto si el cambio en el
tiempo fuera de un minuto si aquí
tuviéramos 0 después 1 después 2 y así
sucesivamente pero observa que nuestro
cambio en el tiempo es de 2 minutos por
lo tanto en este modelo no es cierto
cambio en el tiempo si quisiéramos
modificar este modelo para que fuera
cierto lo que tendríamos que decir es
que nuestra razón 0.8 lo vamos a elevar
a tm sobre 2 y ahora observa este modelo
es cierto porque si el tiempo vale cero
entonces me quedarían cero entre dos lo
cual es cero esto se hace uno y me
quedarían 80 y después si el tiempo
fuera dos minutos tendría dos sobre dos
lo cual es 1 y me quedarían 80 x 0.8
solamente una vez que es lo que pasa
aquí y llegaríamos el valor de 64.3 y
bueno si el tiempo fuera 4 entonces
tendríamos 4 sobre 2 lo cual es 2 y me
quedaría 80 que multiplica a 0.8 que
multiplica a 0.8 que es justo el que
pasaba aquí y para que lo veas con mayor
claridad lo podemos ver aquí no sé si
hacemos una pequeña tabla me voy a tomar
por aquí una pequeña tabla de ponerlo
así y algo más o menos así
y bueno si yo pongo que aquí tenemos al
tiempo y aquí hace de té y vamos a
comprobar esta función qué te parece si
vemos qué pasa cuando el tiempo vale 0
bueno cuando el tiempo vale cero aquí me
quedaría cero entre dos lo cual es cero
0.8 elevado a cero es uno y simple y
sencillamente me quedo con 80 podremos
poner qué pasa con el tiempo vale 1 o
bueno mejor vamos a hacerlo con estos
tiempos que tenemos aquí vamos a ver qué
pasa cuando el tiempo vale 2 cuando el
tiempo vale 2 me quedaría 80 que
multiplican a 0.8 elevado al lado sobre
2 es decir que multiplica a 0.8 elevado
la primera potencia y bueno eso va a ser
muy parecido a 64.3 va a ser una buena
aproximación se va a ajustar los datos
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando el tiempo
vale 4 bueno cuando el tiempo vale 4 me
va a quedar 80 que multiplica a 0.8
elevado
a la 4 entre 24 entre dos es 2 es decir
me quedaría 0.8 elevado al cuadrado y
bueno eso va a ser cercano o una buena
aproximación a 52.7 y si quieres lo
podemos comprobar aquí si yo me tomo mi
calculadora y la pongo por aquí y digo
0.8 esto lo elevó al cuadrado y después
lo multiplicó por 80 voy a llegar a 50 y
1.2 aquí tengo 52.7 pero en verdad esta
es una buena aproximación realmente
estoy ajustando bien los datos así que
aunque hay algo de diferencia puedo
decir que es una buena aproximación así
que déjame quitar la calculadora y
observa cómo este modelo si va
funcionando y es por eso que realmente
me gusta mucho este modelo que tengo
aquí pero si observas no está en ninguna
de mis opciones así que vamos a
escribirlo de otra manera para que se
vea como una de mis opciones
en la que puedo escribir es la siguiente
puedo decir que esto es exactamente
igual que 80 que multiplica a quien
bueno esto va a ser lo mismo que 80 que
multiplica a 0.8 esto elevado a la
potencia un medio y después todo esto
elevado a la potencia de estas dos
expresiones son iguales y bueno si vemos
cuánto es 0.8 elevado a un medio y para
eso voy a traer por acá mi calculadora
vamos a hacerlo y ver cuánto es
esta cantidad de aquí 0.8 elevado a un
médium es exactamente lo mismo que sacar
la raíz cuadrada me va a quedar 0.89
aproximadamente 0.89 así que déjame
escribirlo esto va a ser aproximadamente
aproximadamente 80 lo voy a poner con su
respectivo color 80 que multiplica a
0.89
0.89 esto elevado a la potencia de esto
elevado a la potencia tema ahora observa
0.89 es muy cercano a 0.9 que es esta
opción que tenemos aquí así que ésta se
aproxima muy bien a nuestro modelo que
tenemos es una muy buena aproximación al
modelo que obtuvimos y esta es la forma
en la que más me gusta resolver este
ejercicio porque se me hace una forma de
resolverlo bastante razonable pero tal
vez haya otra forma de resolverlo lo que
se me ocurre es ver las opciones que
tengo acá abajo si observas todas estas
opciones tienen como valor inicial a 80
entonces lo primero que quiero que
descartemos es que es un modelo lineal
porque no tenemos cambios iguales y
entonces nos vamos a fijar en los
modelos exponenciales y si observas
tenemos solamente dos modelos
exponenciales este que tengo aquí
y este que tengo aquí ahora bien podemos
descartar de una manera muy rápida este
modelo que tengo aquí porque se observa
estoy multiplicando por 0.81 cada año y
yo lo que quiero es llegar a ese mismo
valor pero cada dos años por lo tanto de
ninguna manera voy a obtener que cada
dos años multiplique por un factor de
0.81 así que de esa manera descartaría
este que tengo aquí y bueno podemos ver
que este es el modelo que buscamos
porque observa que 0.9 multiplicado por
sí mismo que un cambio de 0.81 cada dos
años que es muy buena aproximación al
factor que tengo y una vez más es por
eso que esta es la opción que más nos
gusta